GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WELCOME TO OUR WEEKLY
SCHEDULE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS A COMMITTEE.
THAT MEETING TODAY.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON BEEN
CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL ALSO
NOTICE THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SO BE.
CONVENING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
JIM OF TWO BILLS ON CONSENT
COUNTY TODAY AT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND ACR ONE
FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
IF WE HAVE NO OBJECTIONS MISTER.
JONES SAWYER HAS ALSO SUBMITTED
A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE AS TO
PRESENTS LATER ON. IN THIS
COMMITTEE DUE TO SCHEDULING
CONFLICTS HE'S
I DON'T CARE ON PUBLIC SAFETY AS
I JUST LEFT THERE. I IN ADDITION
WILL BE HEARING OF BILLS AND
FOLLOW ORDER.
BUT AGAIN WE ARE WE SEE NO
CURRENT OTHER AUTHORS PRESENCE.
AND SO HAVING SAID THAT.
LET US BEGIN THEN.
WITH ITEM NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL WHICH
REPEAT PRESENTED BY VICE CHAIR
BROKE.
AND MILE VICE CHAIR BREAUX'S IS
HEADED DOWN RIGHT NOW ARE ALSO
WANTED TO A FORMALLY WELCOME OUR
NEW CHIEF CONSULTANT TO OUR.
BEING P. COMMITTEE BRENNAN
MCCARTY.
AND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING HIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER.
AND.
VICE CHAIR BROKE. WOULD NOW THAT
WE HAVE THE PODIUM BACK.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WARNING THIS CHAIR MEMBERS.
I TODAY ARISE RESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL WHICH
ESTABLISHES AN OFFICE OF
SUPERVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
BOARDS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. TO ENSURE A
FAIR AND EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER
VOEPEL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
ADDRESS STATE REGULATORY BOARD
MEMBER PERSONAL LIABILITY. THAT
AMEND SECTION EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE WITH THAT
SAID PAST THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BUT YOUR BRO.
ANY MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NO MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME OF ADD
TO THAT MY THING IF YOUR TUNER
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO INDICATE AS
WELL NAME INSTALLATION.
BOB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTING GOOD
MORNING MARCUS MCKINNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT ARM
WITH THE ADOPTION. OF THE
AMENDMENTS TAKING A COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY THERE WERE OFFICIALLY
NO LONGER IN OPPOSITION.
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS MAKE IT ALRIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. ALSO WANTED TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION WITH THE
ADOPTION OF THE AMENDMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR KINDNESS.
THANK YOU.
MARY MCCUEN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
I'M WITH THE ADOPTION OF THE
AMENDMENTS WE WILL ALSO BE
REMOVING ART OPPOSITION AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME SEAMAN ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
A VICE CHAIR BROKE DO YOU WISH
TO CLOSE.
BUT WILL ONLY BE UP BECOME A
FULL COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OF A VERY MATURE
PRESENTATION I ALSO WANTED TO.
PUBLICLY COMMANDS ARE. A
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT ROBERT
SUMNER FOR ALSO WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH MEMBERS THE
MEMBERS OFFICE THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AS WELL AS.
SIGNIFICANT STAKEHOLDERS IN
ADDRESSING OF THIS THESE ISSUES
AN ORDER TO A KIND AND COME TO A
CONCLUSION. AND SUPPORT SO HOW
WE WILL.
REVISIT THAT BILL WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM.
AND.
I KNOW THAT THEN.
WE WILL LOOK FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS AT THIS POINT.
I DON'T CURRENTLY SEEING CME AT
THIS TIME.
SO WE WILL WELL I HONOR.
TRUSTED SERGEANTS TO CONTINUE TO
CALL.
FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
NOW NOTICE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN.
A.
UP MISTER.
.
MY APOLOGIES FOR THIS. HOLDEN
IF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
COMBINATIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY.
HOW WE ARE ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE DUE TO LACK OF QUORUM?
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENCE IN PRESENTING ITEM
NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE.
PLEASE PRESENT WHATEVER IT.
MEMBERS.
LET'S SAVE OUR KITTENS.
WHETHER WE LIKE WHETHER OR
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS WE LOVE
KITTENS.
THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE MEASURE
WHICH ALLOWS KIDS TO BE MADE
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE TO
NONPROFIT RESCUE GROUPS TO PULL
FROM SHELTER.
SPONSORED BY THE ASPCA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
I BELIEVE US SUSAN RIGGS SAID
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THE.
RECONCILED FOR THE PREVENTION OF
CRUELTY TO ANIMALS IS ON HER
WAY.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTING ON.
STILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER CG ANY.
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE.
WHATEVER IT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL CONTROL
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN THE
STATE HUMANE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THAT YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEAMAN ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
CENA WITNESSES SPEAKING
OPPOSITION SU KITTENS ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
KIDDING MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEES MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR I'VE.
SURE ANYTHING IT DO YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN ADDITIONAL.
LISTENS AND SUPPORT IT PLEASE.
APOLOGIZE I WAS IN A DIFFERENT
HEARING.
I THINK THAT'S TODAY.
SUSAN REX WITH THE ASPCA WE ARE
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND YOU
REALLY THIS IS A LIFE SAVING
MEASURE FOR KITTENS IT'S A MINOR
TWEAKS TO EXISTING LAW. THAT CAN
REALLY SAVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS EVERY YEAR
ON THIS CONSISTENT WITH YOU KNOW
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONAL GOALS
ARE TRYING TO REDUCE.
INTAKE AND EUTHANASIA OF
ANIMALS AND WE'VE HEARD YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU
YOU VERY MUCH.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS IT COMES FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CONCLUDING
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
A CLOSE.
AS A MEMBER SUIT YOU WE HAVE.
NOT ESTABLISH A QUORUM AT THIS
TIME STILL.
A SO WE WILL.
.
HAVE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OUT ON
WE HAVE CORN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REPRESENTATION.
OKAY NOW OF WILL WILL GO BACK
THEN TO ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY THREE. IF. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDING THE
.
THANK YOU ACTION BY BEFORE YOU
REPRESENT A SUMMER HOLDEN. WE
NOTICE THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
SO COMEY SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LOW HERE BROUGHT HERE ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
LITTLE.
JILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MAGUS.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH TING.
VIGOROUS WYNONNA STEPS A QUORUM
AS A MEMBER HOLDEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE PRESENT WHEN
EVERYBODY.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO PRESENT IT
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE
TODAY THE BILL WILL CLARIFY THE
PHYSICAL THERAPIST ROLE IN THE
EDUCATION OF YOUNG STUDENTS.
I'LL START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PROPOSED.
BY CO A.
AND CM A TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS.
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK.
WITH THESE TWO ORGANIZATIONS AND
I BELIEVE WE CAN COME TO. A
UNDERSTANDING AND A COMPROMISE
THAT REPRESENTS AND RESPECTS THE
PROTECTIONS OF AB ONE THOUSAND.
AND NO LONGER HINDER STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES FROM GETTING
THE HELP THEY RECEIVED.
BEFORE THE LAW WAS ENACTED.
I HAVE A CHILD HAS A DISABILITY
THE FEDERAL IDA. ACT AND
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRE EDUCATORS
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
PARENTS TO COME TOGETHER AND
CREATE A PLAN THAT ENABLES THE
CHILD TO GET THE BEST EDUCATION
POSSIBLE.
THIS IS CALLED AN INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN OR IEP.
THE IP CAN INCLUDE ANYTHING FROM
WHERE STUDENT SHOULD SIT IN
CLASS TO THE TYPE OF JUST THE
NEED.
TO HOW OFTEN THEY TAKE BREAKS.
THEY CAN ALSO RECOMMEND VISITS
BY PHYSICAL THERAPISTS TO ENSURE
THEIR MOBILITY ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED AND NOT HINDRANCE.
TO THE EDUCATIONAL PROCESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB ONE
THOUSAND WHICH ALLOWS PATIENTS
DIRECT ACCESS TO A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST. FOR FORTY FIVE DAYS
OR TWELVE VISITS BEFORE NEEDING
A MEDICAL DOCTORS REFERRAL.
THIS IS A MAJOR CHANGE FOR
PATIENTS OF PHYSICAL THERAPISTS.
AND IT MEDICAL SETTING.
HOWEVER IT I ACCIDENTALLY
CREATED LIMITATIONS WHERE THERE
WERE NONE OF US NONE FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE WILL
RESTORE THE STUDENTS PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS RELATIONSHIP.
TO WHAT IT WAS BEFORE AB ONE
THOUSAND WAS ENACTED BY
EXEMPTING STUDENTS THAT ARE
DIRECTED TO SEE A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST BY IEP.
FROM THE FORTY FIVE DAY TO
TWELVE VISIT RULE.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
YOU HAVE ABOUT THIS EXCEPTION.
I HAVE WITH ME TO WITNESSES CARL
LONDON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
ASSOCIATION AND DON JAMES.
MY CONSTITUENTS AND A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST THAT SERVES CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES.
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THEM AND THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THE GOVERNMENT PLEASE NEVER READ
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
CARL LONDON HERE MATH
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
DESCRIBED.
WE AS MANY MADE NO AND SOME MAY
NOT KNOW.
FIVE YEARS AGO WE DID A BILL
THAT PERTAIN TO TREATMENT OF
PATIENTS BY PHYSICAL THERAPIST
DIRECTLY. AS KIND OF A.
SAFETY MEASURE COMPROMISE
BETWEEN US IN THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
WE PUT A TRIGGERING AN FOR A
PATIENT TO WHO DOES HAVE SOME
KIND OF A DREAM GHOST A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST.
TO CHECK BACK WITH THEIR OWN
POSITION WITHIN FORTY FIVE DAYS
OR TWELVE VISITS WHICHEVER COMES
FIRST.
NONE OF US CONTEMPLATED WHAT WAS
HAPPENING FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS
OR SO. IN THE EDUCATION
ENVIRONMENT
AND IN THE EDUCATION ENVIRONMENT
AS PART OF A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM PHYSICAL THERAPISTS HAVE
LONG BEEN PROVIDING SERVICES
SCHOOL CHILDREN AND.
IN EARLY INTERVENTION FOR KIDS
ARE REFERRED AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR ZERO
THREE AGE GROUP.
THIS BILL SIMPLY EXEMPTS.
THOSE SITUATIONS IN THE SCHOOL
BASED ENVIRONMENT.
WE LEFT OUT THE AYE OFFICE P.
THE EARLY INTERVENTION PART TO
SORT OF HAVE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH THE OPPONENTS
TO THE BILL THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION OTHERS.
SO WE CAN TRY TO RESOLVE THE
DIFFERENCES THERE.
BUT ESSENTIALLY THIS JUST
RECOGNIZES WHAT HAD BEEN
HAPPENING FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS
BEFORE WE ACCIDENTALLY METAL IN
THAT ENVIRONMENT.
AND TAKES CARE THAT IN JUST A
CRACK FOR THE RECORD WE DIDN'T
TAKE THE ENTIRE AMENDMENT THAT
THE OPPONENTS OFFERED.
WE THERE'S ONE LAST SENTENCE AT
A MEMBER THEY OFFERED THAT WE
DID NOT TAKE BUT WE HAD AN
AGREEMENT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS THOSE.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY DON JEANS
AS MR HOLDEN. SAID WHO IS A
LONGTIME PRACTITIONER IN THIS
FIELD IN SPACE.
AND PROVIDE SERVICES EVERY TO
CHILDREN IT EITHER IN SCHOOLS AS
PART OF THE IEP PROCESS.
OR IN EARLY INTERVENTION WITH
CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME IT
WOULD HAVE IT ADDITIONAL MINUTE
HAVE TO
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING AND MANY MISSED
ON JAMES I'M A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST I HOLD A DOCTORATE
DEGREE IN PHYSICAL THERAPY.
AND I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF THE C.
PEACHES GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
I'M ALSO.
AT PEDIATRIC THERAPISTS ARE
BURKE IN SCHOOLS AND IN EARLY
INTERVENTION.
SO. WHAT?
?
WHAT AB TWENTY THREE OR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE WOULD DO IS TO
HAVE ALLOW US TO TREAT A FEW
CHILDREN WHO SHOW UP IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS A VERY
MINIMAL NUMBER? WITHOUT AN
OFFICIAL MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN DO YOU HAVE AN
ELIGIBILITY THAT HAS BEEN
DETERMINED BY AN IEP TEAM
HOWEVER AT TIMES.
IT IS DONE BY THE ELIGIBLE HE'S
BEEN DETERMINED BY AN IEP TEAM
RATHER THAN A PHYSICIAN. AND IP
TEAM IS MADE UP OF EDUCATORS
INCLUDING SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
SPEECH THERAPIST OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST. PARENTS.
AND PHYSICAL THERAPISTS SO WE
EVALUATE THE CHILDREN DETERMINE
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE. SO THEY
CAN ACCESS THEIR EDUCATION
PROGRAM SO THAT'S WHEN THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY SERVICES WOULD
COME INTO PLAY.
SO THESE ARE NOT CHILDREN.
THE COVERED UNDER THIS
PARTICULAR LANGUAGE THAT HAVE
SEVERE MEDICAL. DISABILITIES
THOSE CHILDREN OF RD BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND ARE BEING
FOLLOWED BY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME
AND THANK YOU FOR RICHARD
JOINING US HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SITTING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
NOW ASK FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO COME UP TO THE PODIUM.
AND AGAIN WHAT LAW UP TO THREE
MINUTES.
PLEASE WHATEVER IT.
A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PRICE DOUGHERTY WITH
KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION. AT THE OUTSET NAM
WHEN I THINK COMMITTEE STAFF AND
OF THE AUTHOR. AND SPONSORS
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE DILIGENTLY
IN THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS EVEN
OVER THE WEEKEND.
WE ARE A.
.
CARL'S CORRECT WE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PROPOSED TODAY.
ARE HALF A LOAF WE WERE.
TALKING ABOUT NARROWING THE
APPLICABILITY OF THE EXEMPTION
BUT NUMBER TWO THE ONE THING
THAT WERE PRINCIPALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT. WHICH UNFORTUNATELY THE
MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF WHAT WE
WERE TRYING TO DO. IS THESE KIDS
ARE.
KIDS THAT DO NOT HAVE A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS FROM A PHYSICIAN.
THERE ARE ENOUGH WITH ME TODAY
IS DOCTOR BASIL BASH PRESENT
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION WHO CAN SPEAK MORE
INTELLIGENTLY ABOUT THIS THE
NINE BUT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THOSE KIDS THAT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN RENDERED A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS.
WHO HAVE CONDITIONS THAT MAKES
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR THE I EP THAT
COULD BE DELAYED ONSET UNDERPAID
MEDICAL UNDERPINNING ISSUES? AND
ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR AT SOME
POINT DURING THAT I EP PROCESS.
VERBALLY BEFORE THE LIMITATION
ON THE P. T. VISITS OR TIME FOR
TREATMENT EXPIRES. THAT THAT
WERE ENSURE THAT THE I EP OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WORKING ON THAT
IEP MAKE SURE THAT THAT KID IS
EVALUATED BY A PHYSICIAN.
AND THAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
NOW SOME OF THESE KIDS COME TO
PHYSICAL THERAPIST BY REFERRAL
FROM A PEDIATRICIAN. THERE MAY
BE PHYSICIANS INVOLVED IN THE
TREATMENT PLAN EVEN THOUGH
MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS HAS IT BEEN
RENDERED BUT THE LAST RUBICON
THAT WE WANNA CROSSES THESE KIDS
ARE. ARE COMPROMISED AND THEY'RE
IN A IN A IN A PROGRAM FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT THEY'RE
NOT PARTICULARLY HEALTHY KIDS
BUT THEY ALSO ARE KIDS THAT
DON'T HAVE A CHRONIC CONDITION
THAT RENDERS A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS.
AND SO AT SOME POINT WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THE PHYSICIAN AND
IS INVOLVED IF NOTHING ELSE
PROVIDE THAT WITHOUT DIAGNOSIS.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
OF THE WRIST THE TIME TO DOCTOR
BASH.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU COMMITTEE
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
CMMITTEE MY NAME IS BASIL
BASHAM CURRENTLY PRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO JUST GIPSON CLINICAL
BACKGROUND ON THIS OKAY
TYPICALLY THERAPISTS WILL TREAT
PATIENTS
WHO HAVE A PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIPTION AND A DIAGNOSIS IS
PRETTY REASONABLE SECOND TO A
PHARMACIST. NOT DISPENSING
MEDICATIONS WITHOUT A
PRESCRIPTION.
WE REALIZE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME EXEMPTIONS AND THEY SHOULD
BE NARROW.
IN THIS CASE WHEN.
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE WITH THE
THERAPIST REST OPEN MINDEDLY
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM AND THEY
POINTED OUT TO US THAT
SOMETIMES.
THESE KIDS COME UP TO THE AND OF
THE FORTY FIVE DAY LIMIT AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
POSITION.
AND WE OFFER TO HELP SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM
CREATING NETWORKS OF FIGURING
OUT HOW WE CAN GET PHYSICIAN
INVOLVEMENT IN TO THE IP
PROGRAM.
BUT THE CURRENT LAST HURDLE IS
THE AMENDMENT TO HAVE A REFERRAL
TO A PHYSICIAN WITHIN TWENTY ONE
DAYS.
OF INITIATING A PHYSICAL THERAPY
PROTOCOL IT'S NOT UNREASONABLE
LET ME TELL YOU WHY CLINICALLY.
LET THESE PATIENTS WILL GET INTO
THIS IP PROGRAM FOR SOMETHING
THAT SEEMS TRIVIAL LIKE A
SYMPTOM A LACK OF COORDINATION
PERHAPS.
INABILITY TO USE A PENCIL
ABSOLUTELY THEY NEED TO HAVE
SOME THERAPY
BUT ALSO CAN BE A TRIGGER
SOMETHING MUCH MORE SERIOUS.
OKAY THINGS LIKE MUSCULAR
DYSTROPHY CEREBRAL PALSY A BRAIN
TUMOR.
WE WENT FROM HOW CAN WE HELP YOU
SOLVE YOUR PROBLEM OF GETTING
THESE KIDS INTO PHYSICIAN TO
PROPOSING THIS AMENDMENT AND
HEARING NO. WE DON'T WANT THEM
TO SEE THAT PHYSICIAN.
THE AMENDMENT TO SIMPLE IT IS
SEVERAL WORDS ALL IT SAYS IS IF
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THERAPY IS
PART OF THE IEP PROGRAM. INVOLVE
A PHYSICIAN ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS PULL THE TRIGGER ON A
REFERRAL. JUST A REFERRAL
NOTHING MORE
TO SAY THAT THE PHYSICIAN
SHOULDN'T BE PART OF THE
TREATMENT TEAM AT ALL. DOESN'T
SEEM TO MAKE SENSE WE'RE GONNA
HURT SOME KIDS IN THIS IS A VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
THIS IS A POPULATION WHERE YOU
SEE THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG IT'S
UP ABOUT YES SIR. AND THEY'RE
MUCH MORE SERIOUS DIAGNOSES
WHY WOULDN'T WE WANT ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO CALL MY IN
INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
I GOT MORE NUMBER ONE I WANT
THOMAS REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WANNA THINK THE AUTHOR FOR.
TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE IN.
LETTER THAT WELL WE WROTE TO
THE COMMITTEE.
.
BOB THAT THIS POINT ABOUT CMA
WOULD THE SINCE HE TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD REMOVE ITS
OPPOSITION HOWEVER. OVER THE
WEEKEND SOME ADDITIONAL CONCERNS
ARE AROSE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO REMAIN OUT AT
THE TABLE AS STAKEHOLDERS I
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED.
BY THE WORTH OF PIZZA THAT. CAN.
I WAS SO EASILY BE FIXED I THINK
IT'S VERY CLOSE TO BEING FIX AND
ALSO.
WE MOVE OUR OPPOSITION BUT.
WILL WILL I KEEP AN EYE ON THE
BILL.
COULD YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES QUESTIONS
BEGIN OPPOSITION.
SEEM NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
KUNO MEMBERS AT THIS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER SOME
INCREASING THANK YOU AND MISTER
CHAIR AND I THINK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND ALL THE
PARTIES-YOU'RE TRYING TO.
PROVIDE THE CARE NEEDED FOR KIDS
AND. I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS PROBABLY IN A YEARS LONG
CONVERSATIONS I APPRECIATE THAT.
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR.
PROPONENTS AND ALSO FOR THEM
ORTHOPEDIC SURGEON SO. THE
DOCTORS HE MENTIONED.
SO REVIEW HERE YOUR PHYSICAL
THERAPIST
THANK YOU AND MAKES THIS IS JUST
A FEW KIDS.
THAT MOST HAVE A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS WHEN THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
HOW MANY IS A FEW?
BUT WHAT'S YOUR BASIS FOR SAYING
THAT IF YOU ARE WHAT WHAT KIND
OF FUTURE WE CAN WOULD GIVE YOUR
BEST ESTIMATE ANY BASIS FOR.
I WOULD SAY IN IN MY ESTIMATION.
SOME MY EXPERIENCE SAY MAYBE
ABOUT THREE PERCENT OF THE KIDS
THAT I EVALUATED.
DURING THE YEAR DON'T HAVE A ONE
OF THEM AND.
DE EVERY PAPER BASED ON WHAT
YOU'RE EVEN GREET YOU AT WHAT
POINT WOULD THAT CHILD.
BE REFERRED TO A DOCTOR IF
EVERYTHING WENT YOUR WAY.
BASED ON OUR PRACTICE ACT
WHENEVER A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
DETERMINES THAT A CHILD HAS
NEEDS OUTSIDE OF OUR SCOPE.
WE'RE REQUIRED TO REFER THEM
ALREADY.
SO DID THE AMENDMENT THAT
THEY'RE DISCUSSING IS THIS KIND
OF A MOOT POINT AUTHORITY WITHIN
OUR PRACTICE.
THAT'S A REQUIREMENT.
THEY WANT TO PUT A TIMEFRAME ON
IT.
ON WERE REQUIRED TO DO THAT
ALREADY.
OKAY AND I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
AT ALL THE TIME FOR
YEAH SO I COULD BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THOSE FEW KIDS I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU SEE.
AND THAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR.
AND THIS IS DEFINITE MY OF
EXPERTISE BUT TO LOOK AT WHAT.
IS THE BROADER MEDICAL
CONDITION THAT MIGHT BE DEALT
WITH SO I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE THE. PLANT OPPOSITION
AND CHAMPS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WHAT. WHY WOULDN'T WE WANT
THEM TO HAVE TO HAVE THAT WERE
FOR ALL OUT WITHIN A CERTAIN
TIME PERIOD TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING CARE?
THAT THE CONCERNED WITH WITH
PUTTING THAT REFERRAL LANGUAGE.
INTO THE IEP PROCESS IS ACTUALLY
IF.
A FINANCIAL ISSUE WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IF WE REQUIRE A SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO MAKE A REFERRAL AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS FINANCIALLY.
.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS TO PAY
FOR THAT EVALUATION.
BASED ON THE WAY THAT THE
FEDERAL LANGUAGES IS.
BOARDED AT THE MOMENT SO IS A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST I HAVE TO.
I HAVE TO REFER AT THE MOMENT.
AND JUST NOT
QUITE SURE HOW THAT LANGUAGE
WOULD LOOK.
AT THIS POINT SO THAT'S IF THE
LANGUAGE WOULD IT BE THAT YOU'RE
GONNA THAT THE SCHOOLS THE ONE
THAT'S REQUIRED TO DO YET THE
REFERRAL. DO YOU HAPPEN LET'S
SAY IF IT'S NOT TO SCHOOL BUT
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD SAY WITHIN TWENTY ONE
DAYS YOU HAVE TO HAVE A REFERRAL
TO A DOCTOR.
THIS I JUST BROUGHT HIM AND IF I
IF I MADE THE ISSUE FOR US IS.
LOOKING BACK OF THIS FOR AS I
MENTION FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING THE SERVICE WITH NO
REQUIREMENTS OF ANY KIND.
FIVE YEARS AGO WE GET THE
DIRECT.
ACCESS LAW THAT ALLOWS PATIENTS
WHO HAVE THE INJURY OF SOME TYPE
TO GO SEE A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
RACKLEY.
AND IN THAT WE'RE ALL
CONTEMPLATING.
SPRAINS SPORT MUSCLES ANKLES
THERE'S YOU KNOW WHATEVER THAT
HAPPENS PEOPLE WE CAN LAWYER
TYPE OR OTHERWISE.
HE'D BE ABLE TO GO SEE A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST FOR FORTY
FIVE DAYS OR TWELVE VISITS.
WHEN WE WROTE THAT IN NONE OF US
WERE CONTEMPLATING WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE SCHOOLS FOR
OVER THREE DECADES.
SO WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THIS
BILLS TRIED TO EXEMPT OUT AND
GET THAT SERVICE RIGHT BACK TO
WHERE IT WAS PART US MESSING
AROUND.
WITH THE OTHER ISSUE AND SO
THERE'S NOTHING IN. THAT REALM
TODAY WITH HIS EXISTENCE
THE PAST THIRTY FIVE OR SO
YEARS.
WERE ANY PROBLEMS OF EVER COME
UP.
AND PATIENTS ARE STUDENTS ARE
PURPLE THERE FOR WHEN THEY NEED
TO BE.
BUT YOU ALSO DON'T WANT IN THE
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT UNDER FEDERAL
LAW THE STATE LAWS RELATING TO.
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES RELATED TO
LEARNING.
WHAT YOU DON'T WANT TO DO AS A
HOLD UP IN THE SERVICES THE KIDS
RECEIVE THAT HEALTH SOME ACCESS
THOSE THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AS
FULLY? AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT WERE I THINK
UNDER DISCUSSION IS TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
HOLD UP SERVICES.
BUT STILL HEDGES AGAINST
WHATEVER THESE NEW ISSUES ARE
THAT MIGHT COME UP THAT I'VE
NEVER COME UP BEFORE. BUT MAY
COME UP AND.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WORDS OR
HASHING OVER WE'VE DONE MOST OF
IT TO CONTEMPLATE THIS AND.
THERE'S NOT ANY EFFORT HERE TO
SKIRT KIDS NOT BEING SEEN A
PURPLE IN FACT.
MANY KIDS WENT UP IN THE SCHOOL
BE SYSTEM OR IN THEIR EARLY
INTERVENTION SYSTEM COME
DIRECTLY FROM. PHYSICIAN
REFERRALS ANYWAY WITHOUT A
DIAGNOSIS. SO WERE WERE SORT OF.
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE PLACE WE DON'T
WANT A HOLD OF THE SERVICES THE
KIDS ARE GETTING JUST BECAUSE
THIS.
HOPE WE FOUND WHERE WERE.
HAGGLING OVER JI ARE YOU
HANDLING KIDS PROPERLY IN THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ISSUE.
BUT WE STEPPED INTO IT WHEN WE
DID THIS FIVE YEARS AGO AND THAT
OF THE BILL IF I COULD THANK YOU
SO.
COMPLETE VERY GOOD POINTS
COMPLETELY GOT THAT FROM YOUR
OPENING IT'S JUST.
IF IT'S A FEW KIDS AND THEY
HAVE NOT RECEIVED A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS I WOULD I I DON'T KNOW
WHY WE WOULD OPPOSE MAKING SURE
THAT THEY. ARE GOING TO AT LEAST
GET A REFERRAL TO A PHYSICIAN
THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND OF
MISTER HOLDEN ITS AREA YOU WANT
ADDRESS BUT. THAT I WOULD WANT
THEM TO SEE THAT I WOULD WANT
THEM TO AND I WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AS A
REQUIREMENT WHETHER IT'S YOU THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR A MANDATE ON
SCHOOL DISTRICT I. I THINK
THAT'S LANGUAGE THAT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE IT'S EVEN BEEN WORKED
OUT.
AND I WANNA OPEN A CAN OF WORMS
BUT AND IF WE IF YOU'RE IS THE
CHAIR WILL BE INTENDED TO PULL
THIS BACK BECAUSE THIS IS
EXACTLY THE COMMITTEE THAT
TO BE SEEN WHAT NEXT AMENDMENTS
COME FORWARD I WOULD I THINK.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHY WE WOULD
OPPOSE MAKING SURE THERE'S A
REFERRAL FOR THESE KIDS WHO HAVE
NOT.
FROM YOUR OPENING TESTIMONY THEY
HAVEN'T SEEN A DOCTOR THEY DON'T
HAVE A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS
NO I'M SORRY I GUESS ALTHOUGH
THEY HAVE NOT SEEN A PHYSICIAN.
I HAVE I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER
COME ACROSS THE CHILD THAT IS
NOT SEEN A PHYSICIAN AND IN THE.
TWENTY SOME YEARS THAT I HAVE
BEEN PRACTICE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS DON'T
HAVE A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS SHUT
AND AS A MATTER OF FACT THE
GUIDELINES.
FROM THE AMERICAN CUT HIM ME A
PEDIATRIC STATE THAT EVEN WHEN A
CHILD DOES NOT HAVE A SPECIFIC
NEURO MOTOR DIAGNOSIS. THAT THEY
CAN BENEFIT FROM EDUCATIONALLY.
BASED THERAPIES. YOU HAVE THAT
PIECE OF PAPER DRIVE YOU THAT
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT OUT OF THE.
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
ON DOCUMENT MAKES VERY CLEAR.
THAT THEIR CHILDREN COME INTO
THE SYSTEMS OFTEN WITHOUT A
MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS
AND FRANKLY.
THERE A LOT OF PARENTS THAT
DON'T KNOW SO WE WANT A LABEL ON
THEIR KIDS THEY GO THROUGH THE
SCHOOL.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING FOR THAT
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR. IS
HEALTH AND SERVICES THAT SUPPORT
THEIR KID ACCESSING THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM IS GENERALLY IN AS FULLY
AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN.
IN THE HOPES THAT THEY HAVE OFF
SOME OF THOSE PROBLEMS THE FULL
REASON WE DO. EARLY INTERVENTION
AND SCHOOL BASED SERVICES AND
THINGS I'VE BEEN THROUGH SETBACK
AT THAT DIRECT EXPERIENCE WITH
WITHOUT IT IS ME AS WELL AT THE
SAME TIME IT WOULD BE.
PORTANTINO.
MAKE SURE.
THAT IT AT SOME POINT THIS IS AN
OPEN ENDED AND I THINK IT WOULD
BE GOOD TO HAVE.
A REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE A
REFERRAL NOW WHETHER IT'S THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I. WOULD ASK
THAT I'M GET TO MY FINAL PART OF
QUESTION THE OTHER SIDE TO SORT
OF ADDRESS AND YOU HAVE
FLEXIBILITY THAT NOT TO STILL BE
A MANDATE ON THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH TELLING
SCHOOLS YOU'RE GONNA BE THE ONES
TO PICK. A DOCTOR NOW FOR THESE
KIDS ARE YOU NOW HAVE A WHOLE
NEW RESPONSIBILITY WE'RE NOT
GONNA FIND BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
FUND IDA AND MANY OTHER THINGS
EDUCATION.
I KNOW IF YOU WANT A DRESS THAT
ONE IF I MAY DO THE CHAIR ARMS
DON'T THOSE ARE. THAT THE
PRECISE BOXES THAT WERE CHECKING
THOSE OF THE TRAPS THAT GONNA
RUN THROUGH WE'RE NOT WEDDED TO
WHAT PRECISELY THE LANGUAGE
LOOKS LIKE. BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE'VE AGREED TO BY WAY OF
EVEN THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS IS
WE ARE ALLOWING. AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE FROM THE VISIT
LIMITATION OF THE TIME THAT A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST CAN TREAT
THESE KIDS BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS
CURRENTLY IS THEY GET TO THE
FORTY FIVE DAY. FORTY SIX DAY
THEY CAN NO LONGER PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES IN THE I EP SO WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS YOU MAY
CONTINUE.
TO TREAT THAT THAT THAT CHILD
WE'RE GRANTING OF THE EXEMPTION
FROM THE TREATMENT LIMITATION
BUT ALL WERE SAYING WHAT WE'RE
REALLY SAYING IS AT SOME POINT.
THAT CHILD NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED
BY A PHYSICIAN IF THE PHYSICIAN
I MEAN WHAT WE CONTINUE TO HEAR
IS THESE KIDS COME TO US BY WAY
OF REFERRAL TO A PEDIATRICIAN.
THERE'S PHYSICIANS INVOLVED IN
CREATION OF THE IEP PHYSICIANS
ARE INVOLVED IN PART OF THE TEAM
AND SIGNING OFF ON TREATMENT
PLANTS.
THAT'S GREAT IF WE CAN CRAFT
LANGUAGE JUST AND GIVES US
COMFORT LEVEL THAT WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT.
ARTIFICIALLY LIMITING KIDS
ACCESS AYE PROGRAMS BUT THE SAME
TIME THERE MAY BE AND I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT MIGHT BE THE
RAINBOW UNICORN CHILD. BUT THERE
THEORETICALLY COULD BE A KID
BASED ON THIS EXEMPTION.
WHO GOES TO AN IEP PROGRAM WHO
IS TREATED BY PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS WHO CAN HOLD A PENCIL
PROPERLY? PHYSICAL THERAPY
EXERCISE ON A KID WHO CAN WILL
PENCIL PROPER PROPERLY IS NOT
GOING TO HELP THAT CHILD IF THE
CHILD IS THE ROCK. OR SOMETHING
TO THAT EFFECT.
THAT THE MANDATORY.
REQUIREMENT PHYSICAL THERAPIST
THAT THEY MERELY REFERS
SOMETHING'S OUTSIDE OF THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
IS IS EXCELLENT AND WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A KID THAT
DOESN'T OF A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS.
THE KID ISN'T WELL YOU KNOW YOU
GET IN THAT SITUATION IS IF IT'S
LATE ONSET SOMETHING WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FOR
SHE WAS EYEBALL.
AT THAT AND THAT SOUNDS
REASONABLE TO ME I'M I ALSO
DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM I HAVE TO
STOP THEIR IP.
WELL WELL SOMETHING IS PENDING I
I HOPE THAT CAN BE WORKED OUT
AND I'M. VERY SYMPATHETIC TO ARE
YOU GOING WITH THIS AND.
.
I DON'T KNOW I'M NOT GONNA THROW
MONKEY WRENCHES THAT. THIS
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME WHERE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN WORKED OUT YET
IN FOLKS ARE WORKING HARD ON IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THIS
AGAIN THIS IS MY CHANCE TO SEE
IT AND IT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE.
.
SO. I THINK YOU ARE YOU MIGHT
COME IN ON THEMAS CHAIR THANK
YOU YES OUR DUES US SO AFTER
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
AND.
THINGS AND SO ON WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO US IN THE RECENT
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR. OF JUST LOOK I HEARD
THE COMMENT ABOUT THAT THE
UNICORN RAINBOW CHILD.
WHOEVER THAT MAY BE THE
QUESTION WAS ASKED ABOUT HOW
MANY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NEW GAVE A
PERCENTAGE OF ABOUT THREE
PERCENT.
OUT OF THAT THREE PERCENT HOW
MANY.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THAT ARE
GETTING THROUGH WITHOUT A
MEETING OF POSITION.
OR BEING BEING REVIEW AT I DON'T
HAVE A. IT.
AN ANSWER THAT'S GOING TO BE
SHORT THAT LET ME JUST CLARIFY
TWO OR THREE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE IN CONTEXT OF THAT QUESTION
IF I MAY NUMBER ONE IS.
IF YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE
ICD NINE BEING CONVERTED ICD TEN
WE'VE GONE FROM. ROUGHLY TEN
THOUSAND DIFFERENT COATS TO NOW
OVER SIX
THE FIVE THOUSAND CODES IS A LOT
OF COMEDY IN THE INTO.
THERE'S A CODE FOR ABOUT LEFT
ARM INJURY ORCA.
NON ACUTE RIGHT SO THERE'S A
DIAGNOSIS FOR EVERYTHING
SO THIS CONCEPT OF US MAKING AN
ARTIFICIAL DELINEATION BETWEEN
NOT HAVING SEEN THE PHYSICIAN
VERSUS NOT HAVING A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS IS THAT IT'S
ARTIFICIAL.
THE KEY IS IS THAT THESE FOLKS
NEED TO BE SEEN AND THAT. NOT
JUST GIVEN THE DIAGNOSIS BUT
HAVING A DIAGNOSIS RULED OUT
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WRONG
I'LL GIVE YOU A STORY ABOUT
MYSELF.
WHEN I WAS SIX SEVEN EIGHT YEARS
OLD I WAS NOT PARTICULAR
COORDINATED HOW BECAME A HAND
SURGEON.
ANYONE'S GUESS I AM WHEN I RAN.
THE OTHER KIDS PARENTS WILL MY
MOM ASIDE AND SAID YOU SHOULD
GET HIM CHECKED OUT FOR SURE
BILL PALSY.
NOW LUCKILY MY MOTHER WAS A
PEDIATRICIAN AND I DIDN'T HAVE
CEREBRAL PALSY BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY THE KIND OF KID WE DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE.
A KID WHO PRESENTS WHAT SOME
LACK OF COORDINATION AND THEY'RE
GETTING TREATMENT.
BEFORE EITHER A DIAGNOSIS OR
RULE OUT OF DARKNESS.
I CAN'T GIVE YOU PERCENTAGES BUT
WE WANT TO LOSE EVEN ONE OF
THOSE.
CHAIRMAN IF I MAY HAVE JUST
COULD RESPONSE THAT I MEAN IT
JUST REMINDED ME HERE THAT. THIS
IS GOING ON FOR THIRTY FIVE
FORTY YEARS PRIOR WE
INADVERTENTLY CREATIVE PROBLEM
IN THE EDUCATIONS.
FOR KIDS GETTING IP SERVICES AND
FOR KIDS GETTING EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES.
BECAUSE OF A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION AROUND.
PHYSICAL THERAPY INTERVENTION
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOME KIND OF
INJURY AND GO SEEK PHYSICAL
THERAPY TREE.
NONE OF US CONTEMPLATED THE
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES THAT WERE
GOING ON AT THAT TIME
OR EARLY INTERVENTION.
THERE'S NO HISTORY OR EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER.
OF ANY KIND OF ISSUE OR LACK OF
REFERRAL BY PHYSICIANS.
WHEN ANY OF THESE KINDS OF KIDS
COME OUT AND WE'RE BOUND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BILL IN FRONT OF
YOU.
SUBSECTION A ONE WAS JUST
EXISTING LAW.
BYNES PHYSICAL THERAPISTS TO THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY MUST REFER
IF THEY SEE THINGS AGO OUTSIDE
THEIR SCOPE WHERE THEY NEED
FURTHER CONTEMPLATION BY
PROFESSIONAL. THAT EXCEEDS WHAT
THEY OFFER WAS DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT THEY OFFER.
THIS EXEMPTION THAT WE HAVE DOES
NOT.
ALLOW US AN EXEMPTION FROM A ONE
IT ONLY ALLOWS US AN EXEMPTION
FROM A FOR.
WHICH IS THE SECTION THAT DEALS
WITH THE FORTY FIVE DAY TWELVE
DOES IT.
THINGS WERE WERE LITERALLY
TRYING TO SATISFY.
SCHOOLS AND THE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES PROBLEM
THAT WE CREATED.
WHEN WE ARE CONTEMPLATING
PATIENTS GOING IN AND GETTING
HURT PLAYING SOFTBALL OR DOING
WHATEVER THEY ARE GOING TO SEE A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST SO YEARS SO
IT'S MEN I MEAN WE HAVE
LITERALLY IF THIRTY FIVE FORTY
YEAR TRACK RECORD.
A PHYSICAL THERAPIST DOING
EXACTLY WHAT GOES ON IN THE
SCHOOLS LIKE PEAS AND TO EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES.
WITHOUT ONE INSTANCE
OF US EVER MISSING UPON THAT AND
NOTHING'S GONNA CHANGE IN THAT.
WITHIN A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM.
THROUGH THE SCHOOLS THAT DO
THESE IP PROCESSES
NOTHING CHANGES WERE SO YOU'RE
BASICALLY SAYING THEN THAT.
YOU'RE BOUND TO REFERRAL
WHETHER IT'S DAY TEN OR WHETHER
IT'S STAY FIFTY FIVE THAT'S
RIGHT WE DON'T MISS SEVERAL
POLICY BY THE WAY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF THAT YOU KNOW WE WE
CASA RUN THESE CLAIMS WERE
SUDDENLY GOING TO HAVE A CHILD
WHO.
THERE'S A MESS WE WOULD KNOW
THIS BECAUSE WE ARE MISSING
THESE THINGS CANCER OTHERWISE.
YOU KNOW WE WOULD GET SUED
EVENTUALLY THAT DOESN'T SHOW UP
ANYWHERE OUR LIABILITY TRACK
RECORD WITH IT LEGISLATURE'S
THING SECONDLY COMPLAINTS WHICH
IS OFTEN THE LICENSING BOARD
WHENEVER I AM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. W. WE CAN GO TO HAVE A
FEW ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
ADMIT THIS POINT A DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
.
I'M CONFLICTED ON THIS BILL AND
I REALLY FEEL THAT I MUST SHARE
SOME OF IT FOR THE GOOD OF THIS.
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO FOR THE
AUTHOR.
RESPECT THAT YOU BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD YOU IT SEEMS LIKE THE
SPONSORS ARE REALLY ATTEMPTING
TO FIX UP.
AN ISSUE THAT IS BROUGHT FORWARD
BY THE PASSAGE
OF AB ONE THOUSAND BUT AB ONE
THOUSAND IS THE LAW FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I LOOK TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE NEXT LAWS WERE PASSING ARE
ACTUALLY FIXING A.
AN ISSUE IN A CORRECT WAY
AND MY COMMENTARY IF I CAN JUST
FROM HEARING THE DELIBERATION OF
THIS COMMITTEE IS IT'S NOT QUITE
COOKED YET.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T
GET TO A PLACE BUT I FEEL I NEED
TO SHARE THE FACT THAT I'M NOT
IN A VOTE FOR THIS TODAY NOT
BECAUSE I DON'T.
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR DOESN'T HAVE
IT WITHIN HIS HEART TO FIX
PROBLEM BUT. WE HAVEN'T REACHED
AN END POINT THAT NEEDS ALL OF
OUR NEEDS AND.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS?
THE SUPPORTERS SAY THEY BATTED
A THOUSAND FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
AND I FIND THAT HARD TO BELIEVE
ON ITS FACE.
THAT YOU'VE GONE EVERY ISSUE
ALWAYS PERFECT.
AND WHAT I WONDER IS WHAT ROLE
WE S.. CAN PLAY IN.
IN THIS INTERFACE IN IS THERE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO BE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT FROM
PLACE TO HELP TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE'RE CATCHING EVERYTHING.
I DON'T WANT TO LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR PHYSICAL THERAPIST
TO DO THEIR JOB WELL.
I THINK THEY'VE DONE IT WELL.
BUT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
AND.
I.
JUST WANTED TO ADD MY TWO CENTS
IN MY COMMENTS FOR WHERE I AM
BUT IF WE ARE ABLE TO GET THIS
BILL TO A PLACE WITH AMENDMENTS.
I CAN SEE MYSELF VOTING FOR THIS
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THAT.
CONTINUE DIALOGUE AND WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS AS THIS BILL.
CONTINUES TO SOME.
THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU AYE AYE YEAH LOOK I.
I RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THAT
THERE IS A.
SORT OF A DISCONNECT ON IN TERMS
OF HOW. WE'RE OPERATING UNDER
FEDERAL LAWS AND THEN OF COURSE
UNDER OUR STATE LOSS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS.
OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WE ARE
TRYING HARD TO MAKE SURE DO NOT
FALL.
BETWEEN THE CRACKS IN THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO GET. A PROPER
EDUCATION.
AND WE WORK VERY HARD TO THIS
POINT. WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE CHAIR.
AND WITH THOSE WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION ONE PARTY HAS REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION ALTHOUGH
THERE'S INDICATION.
OF CONTINUING TO WALK TO WORK
WITH US AND WE CONTINUING TO ONE
AND WORK WITH THEM. AND SO I
THINK THAT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT.
WE SHOWED GREAT.
DILIGENCE IN TERMS OF TRYING TO.
JUST NOT HERE. OF WHAT WAS
BEING SAID AS CONCERNS BUT TO
REALLY TAKE SOME CORRECTIVE.
ACTIONS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SHARPEN. OF THE POINTS THAT I
THOUGHT NEEDED TO BE MADE AND TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES TO THE BEST
OF OUR ABILITY.
AS I INDICATED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT WE WILL CONTINUE. TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION WILL
CONTINUE TO. OF FIND WAYS THAT.
THE ISSUE OF REFERRALS AND
GRAMMY.
EXPANDING OR INCLUDING AS MANY
VOICES.
AND THE TRIALS OF DEVELOPMENT
ARE CAN BE MADE AS POSSIBLE.
BUT WE ALSO WERE OPERATING
UNDER.
CERTAIN LIMITATIONS THAT ALLOWS.
TO KEEP US FROM GOING MAYBE AS
FAR. AS WE WOULD LIKE OR WOULD
NEED TO SO I CAN ONLY COMMIT
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO.
THE OTHER KIND OF DUE DILIGENCE
AND.
COOPERATIVE FOR.
WORKING TOGETHER.
TO TRY TO HAVE THE BEST BILL
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I'M NOT. I SEE THE SAME WAY AS
YOU AND EVERYONE ELSE I I WON A
BILL THAT'S GOING TO MAKE.
THE SITUATION BETTER AB ONE
THOUSAND CREATED SORT OF THESE.
IMPRESSIONS THAT WE NEEDED TO
DO SOMETHING TO SORT OF SHORING
UP.
AND THAT.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME.
THAT A BILL HAS COME BACK COME
BEFORE US TO TRY TO GO BACK AND.
TO TRY TO MAKE SOMETHING BETTER
THERE WAS OUR INTENTION TO SEE
ADDRESS THAT MAY NOT HAVE. ALL
BEEN DONE.
AS THOROUGHLY AS POSSIBLE AND
SO. ARE WE OPEN OURSELVES UP
CONTINUING TO.
TO USE TO SEEK A MORE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE.
IT'S A VERY LUCKY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
HOLTON NEXT QUESTION COMES FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO THOUGHT THAT
THOSE WERE HOLDS.
SENATOR.
NTFC IT TO ME MISTER GOLDMAN.
AND AND I WOULD SUPPORT THE
BILL.
TODAY I TAKE YOU AT YOUR WORD
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THESE ISSUES AS WE ALL
DO WHEN WE WILL MOVE BILLS.
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
I HAVE.
BUT.
I I'M FRANKLY.
OKAY WITH THE BILL THE WAY IT
IS IN ITS CURRENT FORM. OF
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS ARE ARE.
TRAIN HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
THEY'RE A VERY VALUABLE PART OF
THE.
HEALTHCARE TEAM AND THEY'RE
TRAINED TO RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND WHEN THERE NEEDS TO
BE A PHYSICIAN REFERRAL. I'VE
HEARD NO EVIDENCE THAT THAT
DOESN'T. KNOW WHAT IT IS TODAY
THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN WHEN IT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN. AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF ANY EVIDENCE.
I JUST DON'T SEE OF WHAT LIES
BILL IS NOT RIGHT MOVE FORWARD
SO I'M HAPPY TO.
SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS BLOOM WAS
A.
THANK YOU A.
THINKING ABOUT MUCH YOU DON'T
BRING THIS BILL FOR I'LL ALSO BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY INTERESTED
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES.
I.
WE'RE DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE
RIGHT NOW AS YOU MIGHT WAY FOR
SICK LAST YEAR PRETTY SEVERE BUT
A SPINAL TUMOR. THAT IS GONNA
NEED ONGOING PHYSICAL THERAPY
AND OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND
EVERY TIME WE HIT THAT.
SIX
SIX VISITS OR WHATEVER VISITS
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED WE HAVE TO
GO BACK AND GET A REFERRAL AGAIN
WHICH CAN STOP TREATMENT FOR UP
TO A MONTH FREQUENTLY.
FREQUENT UP TO A MONTH THAT WE
HAVE TO THEN WAIT TO GET ANOTHER
REFERRAL. TO GO BACK AGAIN ON
AND THAT DELAY IN SERVICES I CAN
TELL YOU IS.
IS IS SIGNIFICANT WHAT IT CAN
DO ESPECIALLY THEN FOR A CHILD
WHO IS DEVELOPING THE LONG. A
SOMEBODY IN THEIR LATE FIFTIES
TRYING TO RECOVER FROM
SOMETHING.
SO I JUST YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THESE ISSUES AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THEIR YOU KNOW THE
POSITION NEEDS TO HAVE THEIR
EYES ON THERE BUT YOU'RE RIGHT
I.
WE HAVE NEIGHBORHOODS GOT A
THREE YEAR OLD WHO IS NOW HAS AN
IEP AND IS GETTING SERVICES AND
SHE GOT THE SERVICE BECAUSE
BECAUSE YOU DOCTOR REALIZE AT
FIRST NOW. WOULDN'T KNOW SHE'S
IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
SO I JUST CAN'T CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AND I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I THINK. ANY
TIME WE CAN MAKE SERVICES BE
CONSISTENT AND AND ESPECIALLY
WE'RE SEEING PROGRESS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THOSE NOT STOP TO GO
BACK TO SOME BILLS AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN DO WHICH
THE CLOSER EXISTING CAPS LATE
WOULD YOU JUST
PREVIOUSLY SAID AS HER THOUGHTS
INTO.
OF LET ME JUST SAY THAT I.
I RECEIVE THE THE CONCERN AYE
AYE KNOWLEDGE THE CONCERN I
THINK. WE HAVE A CONCERN BEFORE
BY STEPPED TO THE MICROPHONE IN
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW. WE CAN TAKE ADDITIONAL
STEPS TO.
BUT TO MAKE IT.
MORE RESPONSIVE AND REFLECTIVE
OF THE ISSUE OF REFERRALS AND
HOW TO CONTINUE TO. ENGAGE THE
PHYSICIAN AND THIS PROCESS AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT I THINK WE'VE
COME A LONG WAY IN TERMS OF.
COVERING A LOT OF THE GROUND
THAT WAS LAID OUT THERE WHEN WE
STARTED THIS PROCESS IN TERMS
OF.
.
OBJECTIONS OR OUR CONCERNS TO
HOW THIS BILL WAS GOING TO
ADDRESS.
MOVE IN THE WAY THAT IT DID IT
SO.
ARE I CAN JUST AGAIN COMMITTEE
YOU THAT WE WILL.
I CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS.
AS A CONTINUING DIALOGUE THAT
WILL LEAD HOPEFULLY TO.
SOME TYPE OF A.
A SOLUTION THAT GETS US CLOSER
TO GOAL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WERE HOLDEN A.
I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE FROM
THE COMMITTEE THEMSELVES CELLS
IN THE MEMBER'S COMMENTS AND I
HOPE THAT YOU AS THE AUTHOR WILL
ENCAPSULATE AND MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
WITH RESPECT TO MOVING FORWARD
ON THE ISSUE.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT WE DID
RECEIVE OPPOSITION LATE I WITH
AMENDMENTS ARE ON SATURDAY BUT
HAVING SAID THAT WE HAVE ALSO.
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF BEEN
WORKING WITH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION IN TRYING TO WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE INCOMING TO A
REASONABLE AGREEMENT.
AND THAT IS OUR.
AND ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT YOU'VE
ALSO EQUALLY COMMITTED AS YOU
SAID PUBLICLY HER TODAY THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS MOVING
FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY WE WILL RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO CALL THIS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE A SHOULD NOT FALL IN
THE SPIRIT IN THE INTEREST OF
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP.
AND MR HOLDEN SO I HAVING SAID
THAT THIS DOES ENJOY AND AYE
RECOMMENDATION A IS THERE A
MOTION.
MOVED AND SECONDED ALCHEMY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LOW. IP LOW I. BROKE.
WE'RE NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOT BETTING BAKER.
BIGGER NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN BY PULLING AYE.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
WHOLE YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE RELEVANT FOR
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M WILL NOW MOVE ON BECAUSE WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL AUTHOR AND WHO I
KNOW IS. CONCRETELY CHAIRING
ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT HIS CAME
OUT OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE MISTER JONES
SAWYER THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF. AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE IT CANNABIS LICENSE
APPLICANT PROVIDE HE STATEMENT.
ALONG WITH THEIR APPLICATION
A FOR ME THAT THEY WILL EMPLOY
ONE EMPLOYEE THEY WILL EXPLOIT
ONE EMPLOYEE AND ONCE SUPERVISOR
TRAINED AND CAL OSHA.
PACIFIC THEY JUST BILL WILL
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYEES TAKE
THE CAL OSHA THIRTY HOURS
GENERAL INDUSTRY TRAINING WITHIN
ONE YEAR OF THE CAMPUS APPLICANT
RECEIVING THEIR LICENSE.
CANNABIS IS A NEW AND RAPIDLY
GROWING INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
AT THIS BILL AS INDUSTRY GROWS
IT SHOULD BE A PRIORITY TO
CANVASSED BUSINESSES ARE
FAMILIAR WITH CALIFORNIA'S
WORKPLACE SAFETY REGULATIONS
THAT ORDER TO PREVENT NEEDLESS
HARM TO WORKERS.
REQUIRING EMPLOYEES TO BE
TRAINING CAL OSHA STANDARDS WILL
PROVIDE THEM WITH KNOWLEDGE OF
COMMENT JOB RELATED HAZARDS AND
HOW TO AVOID THEM ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRING THAT SUPERVISORS
THOROUGHLY UNDERSTAND HOW TO
MAINTAIN A SAFE WORKPLACE. WILL
LEAD TO BUSINESSES AVOIDING
COSTLY FINES DURING INSPECTIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE IS JIM ARABY
ZECCA DIRECTOR OF UFCW WESTERN
STATES COUNSEL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT PLEASE
WHATEVER RIGHT.
JIM AND MEMBERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JERRY AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
USC W. WESTERN STATES COUNSEL.
REPRESENTING MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING MEMBERS IN
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY I AM
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS BILL AND
WELCOME SUPPORT OF THE
TEAMSTERS.
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND WORK SAFE FOR THE
BILL AS WELL.
NEVER BEFORE IN THE HISTORY THE
STATE HAS A WIDESPREAD AND
WIDESPREAD INDUSTRY LONG SKILLED
OPERATING OUTSIDE THE LAW.
ALL OF A SUDDEN BECOME LEGAL
EXPECTED TO COMPLY WITH ALL LOS.
INCLUDING WORKPLACE SAFETY LAWS
THAT PREVENT MY MEMBERS IN YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM DYING BEING
INJURED OR FALLING ILL.
JUST SOME OF THE HAZARDS IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY FOR THOSE WHO
WORK IN INCLUDE HEAT ILLNESS.
EXPOSURE TO PESTICIDES CARBON
DIOXIDE FROM AIR RICHMAN
PROCEDURES USING DRY ICE TANKS
OF COMPRESSED CARBON DIOXIDE.
WRIGLEY TO ACCELERATE AND
IMPROVE PLANT GROWTH.
CARMEN OXIDES IN THE USE OF FUEL
BURNING EQUIPMENT EXPOSURE TO
EQUIPMENT WITH EXPOSE ROTATING
CUTTING OR PINCHING HAZARDS USED
TO PROCESS AND DESTROY WASTE
PLANT PRODUCTS.
FLAMMABLE IN CHEMICAL HAZARDS
WHILE PERFORMING EXTRACTIONS.
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE REPEATEDLY
REPEATEDLY ATTEST TO THIS NEW
INDUSTRIES LACK OF AWARENESS OF
THE CALIPHATE PROGRAM. BASIC
EMPLOYER WORKPLACE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WORKERS
RIGHTS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE
APPLICANTS FOR ANY TYPE OF
CANVAS LICENSE PROVIDE A
STATEMENT THAT THE APPLICANT
EMPLOYEES OR WILL EMPLOY WITHIN
ONE YEAR OF RECEIVING A LICENSE.
JUST ONE SUPERVISOR AND JUST ONE
EMPLOYEE WHO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED THE CAL OSHA. THIRD OF
DIRTY OUR GENERAL INDUSTRY
OUTREACH COURSE ON BEHALF OF MY
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THE REMIX WAS EVERY ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SO FREE TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE A MANIPULATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO.
MISTER CHAIR MAP BROUGHT FROM
BROUGHT INVESTMENT LLP HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO
SUPPORT
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION XENA
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE'S A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER JONES
ARE WHICH YOU WISH TO CLOSE YES
I RESPECT LAST. YOU VERY MUCH.
SITE ON MY APOLOGIES OUT ONE.
THERE TO SHOW HER. A QUESTION
FROM TO MOVIE AND IT IS THERE
ANY I'M I'M BEEN LOOKING AT THIS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION WANTS TO HAVE MORE
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS.
IS THERE ANY.
WE MUST STRINGENT AND CAL OSHA
YEAH WELL WHICH IS HARD TO
BELIEVE BUT I MEAN IF THEY WANT
TO HAVE MORE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
IF THEY WANT TO. HAVE.
MORE RIGOROUS HOURS IN AND LEAVE
IT I DON'T KNOW IF CAL OSHA
WOULD IF THIS WOULD PREEMPT A
LOCAL JURISDICTION BEING ABLE TO
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
I THINK YOU NEED EVEN MORE BUT
I KNOW. AS ONE OF THE AUTHORS OF
THE MEDICAL. CANNABIS AND
WORKING WITH DOING TO THE ADULT
USE AND MEDICAL WE LEFT IT UP TO
LOCAL CONTROL SO I BELIEVE AND
WE CAN DOUBLE CHECK I BELIEVE IN
FACT WE DID LEAVE UP TO LOCAL
CONTROL. SO BIG IF THEY WANT TO
ADD ADDITIONAL MEASURES THEY
CAN'T.
SO WE'LL DOUBLE CHECK ALONG THE
CAL SHOULD STOP PUTTING UP
MACINNES PACKAGE
TO JUST THAT'S THE ONE THING I
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE HAPPENS
IF A LOCAL JURISDICTION.
PERHAPS MY DISTRICT WHERE YOU
TEENS EXPLODED WANTS TO HAVE
EVEN MORE STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF
THAT I DON'T WANT.
FROM DOING IT SHOULD NOT VOTE
SHOULD NOT WITH THE ORIGINAL
BILL. RESULT AUTHORIZATION OF
CANNABIS STATEWIDE WE CAME AND
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED FOR WILL
DOUBLE CHECK FOR YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMES
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS I SEE
NONE THE AUTHOR HAS. CLOSED
GIVEN HIS CLOSING STATEMENT THIS
DOES ENJOY AN AYE RECOMMENDATION
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ACTION IS THE PAST COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT LOW AYE LOW
AYE BROKE.
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
IF YOU'RE NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MAYES.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH TING.
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THIS BILL IS
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
THE.
SECOND TO LAST A BILL.
ON WE SEE FROM ITEM NUMBER.
ONE WHICH IS AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
IRWIN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
FEES PRESENTMENT EVERYONE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB TWO TWO
EIGHT ONE. ALLOWS MEDICAL
LABORATORY TECHNICIANS OR A
MULTISPORT FORM THREE ADDITIONAL
TESTS OF MODERATE COMPLEXITY.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA MULTISPORT
FOR CLINICAL LAB TESTS
CLASSIFIED AS SIMPLE FOR OF THIS
AS MODERATE. AS NOTED IN A
RECENT STUDY BY UCSF ALL OTHER
STATES ALLOW MLT USED TO PERFORM
BOTH MODERATE AND HIGH
COMPLEXITY TESTING WITHOUT
EXCEPTIONS.
THE THREE EXAMS THAT WE ARE
INCLUDING.
.
ARE CONSIDERED OF MODERATE
COMPLEXITY BY THE CLINICAL
LABORATORY IMPROVEMENT
AMENDMENTS CATEGORIZATION AND
MANY ARE PERFORMED USING
INSTRUMENTATION THAT IS
CONSIDERED OF MODERATE
COMPLEXITY. IN ADDITION THERE
ARE READY PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
TO MAINTAIN THE QUALITY OF THESE
TESTS SINCE CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
THAT THE TESTS ARE CONDUCTED BY.
THAT ARE CONDUCTED BY A MULTI IS
BE UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF A
PHYSICIAN. SURGEON OR HIGHLY
EDUCATED PROFESSIONAL THIS BILL
WILL ENABLE TECHNICIANS TO
PRACTICE THE SKILLS THAT THEY
ARE TRAINED FOR. AND THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN THAT AND THAT
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER
STATES ARE READY PERFORMING.
ALSO OUR STATE'S LABORATORIES
WILL GREATLY BENEFIT FROM THIS
IT'S THIS BILL CAN. IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF OUR LAB PERSONNEL.
ALLOWING ADULTS USE TO PERFORM
THESE THREE HIGH VOLUME TESTS
WILL FREE UP THE TIME OF
CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST SO THAT
THEY MAY FOCUS ON THE MOST
CHALLENGING LAB TESTS FOR THESE
REASONS. AB TWO TWO EIGHT ONE
WILL MODERNIZE OUR LABORATORY
WORKFORCE WITH ME HERE IN
SUPPORT IS THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PATHOLOGISTS.
AND THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
LABORATORIES AT UCSF DOCTOR TO.
IT WAS OUR TURN MEMBERS BOB BACK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY PATHOLOGISTS
BUT ALL IT IS OUR POSITION TO
SPECIALIZED LABORATORY MEDICINE
AND WE ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL.
AS A WAY TO ADDRESS WORKFORCE
ISSUES THE WORKFORCE ISSUES AND
HEALTH CARE REFORM ARE OFTEN
DISCUSSED THIS IS A VERY MINOR
CHANGE TO THE LAW.
IF THIS BILL PASSES IT WILL
STILL BE THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
DEFINITION FOR A MULTI USE IN
THE UNITED STATES SO. I HAVE
DOCTOR HAMMILL FROM A FORMER
DRUG ABUSE YOURSELF TALK ABOUT
THE MECHANICS OF THIS. OF BUT
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE.
I'VE BEEN A LABORATORY DIRECTOR
OR WHAT'S LABORATORY DIRECTOR
FOR OVER TWENTY FOUR YEARS I'VE
WORKED FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS ON
LABORATORY WORKFORCE ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND GROWING SHORTAGE
OF QUALIFIED LABORATORY
TECHNOLOGISTS IN THIS STATE OVER
A DECADE AGO. OF THE LEGISLATURE
WISELY PASSED
A LEGISLATION THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR A SECONDARY CATEGORY OF
LICENSURE FOR OUR LABORATORIES
THAT'S THE MLP. A LICENSING
CATEGORY UNFORTUNATELY THE
PRESCRIPTIVE NATURE OF THEIR
SCOPE RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE IN
THAT LEGISLATION HAS LED TO A
PROBLEM WITH LABORATORIES BEING
ABLE TO HIRE. AND RETAIN THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR
LABORATORIES ARE JUST
TOO MANY LARGE VOLUME TESTS THAT
THEY CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN
BECAUSE OF THEIR SCOPE
LIMITATIONS.
WITHOUT THIS MY WORRY IS THAT
WHILE WE'VE GENERATED MLT
TRAINING PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
AND WE ARE NOW TURNING OUT AND
THEY'LL TEASE. MOST OF THOSE ARE
GOING OUT OF STATE TO PRACTICE
BECAUSE THEY CAN DO EVERYTHING
THAT A CLS CAN DO. AND
VIRTUALLY EVERY STATE IN THE
UNION EXCEPT CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT SUCH CHANGES THAT ALLOW
THESE PEOPLE TO BE PLACED IN
CALIFORNIA LABORATORIES. CHANCES
ARE WE'RE GOING TO YOU'D LOSE
THOSE MLT PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
AND FURTHER IN NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE WORKFORCE SHORTAGE A
CALIFORNIANS FACING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME LIKE NAME
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO.
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS LARGE CLINICAL AT
COUNTRY LAB.
COMPANY IN THE COUNTRY THANK
YOU.
SUPPORT.
HOW IT SOUTHERN OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING ABOUT NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT OF ALL THE HOSPITAL BEDS
IN THE STATE IN SUPPORT?
AND HOLY GOD THEMSELVES WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO CHRISTY FOR A WITH A
CALIFORNIA CLICK LABORATORY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HE
DIDN'T KNOW WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEN ON ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PEACEFUL FREE TO COME
UP TO. THE PODIUM.
AND AGAIN YOU HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES.
PLEASE WHEN EVERYBODY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
MATT BROUGHT FROM BROWNING
GASSMAN LLP HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA AYE OF P. T. E. LOCAL
TWENTY. WE HAVE SIX THOUSAND
MEMBERS ACROSS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING BOTH
PENALTIES AND THE MEDICAL AT TAX
IN CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST.
WE STILL RATE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL ARM BUT ONE I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
STAFF FOR. BEING OPEN TO MEETING
WITH US IN HEARING OUR CONCERNS
I'M WE FEEL THAT BLOOD SMEARS
URINALYSIS IN HBO ARE EACH
TESTING. WHICH ARE ALL COMPLEX
OR MODERATELY COMPLEX INVOLVE A
DISCRETIONARY COMPONENT MEANING
THAT THEIR BEST LEFT IN THE
HANDS OF CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST
YOU ARE BETTER TRAINED AND
EDUCATED TO PERFORM THEM.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS
CREATES POTENTIAL ON PATIENT
HEALTH RISKS AS BLOOD SMEARS ARE
USED IN THE DIAGNOSIS. UP
SERIOUS CONDITIONS SUCH AS
LYMPHOMA AND LEUKEMIA AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY A FAULTY BLOOD
TRANSFUSION AND WOOD. COULD BE
DEADLY I'M WE WE DO AGREE
PHILOSOPHICALLY WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN.
I SPEAKING ABOUT WE WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE A SHORTAGE OF
BOTH CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST
MEDICAL LAB TAX ACROSS THE
STATE.
HOWEVER WE THINK THAT WE NEED
MORE TRAINING PROGRAMS NOT TO
TAKE SOME OF THAT THAT.
.
HER EXCUSE ME IT TAKES IN THE
TASKS AND REASSIGN THEM TO
MEDICAL LAB TAX.
ON WE DON'T THINK THAT MEDICAL
LAB TECHS ARE LEAVING THE STATE.
AND TO WORK IN LOWER PAID
OCCUPATIONS JUST SO THEY CAN
PRACTICE.
I'M THEY CAN PRACTICE MORE TESTS
I'M AND. I BROUGHT WITH ME TODAY
MARJORIE BROUGHT SHE'S A
CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST AT THE
KAISER RICHMOND LAB IN THE EAST
BAY AND SHE WANTS TO SAY A FEW
MORE WORDS ABOUT THESE TESTS
THANK YOU. GREATLY ADDITIONAL
ONE MINUTE THANK YOU PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IT'S MY TREE
PROCESS AND.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
GIVE THIS TESTAMENT TO YOU. I AM
A CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST AND I
HAVE A FEELING THAT EXCEPT FOR
MAYBE OUR POSITION ON THE BOARD
MOST IF YOU'VE NEVER HEARD OF
WHAT I DO.
AND AS A A CLINICAL LABORATORY
SCIENTISTS THE PHYSICIANS RELY
ON EIGHTY PERCENT OF THEIR
DIAGNOSIS IS BASED UPON THE
TESTING THAT I DO.
I ALSO WANNA POST.
TELL YOU ABOUT THE TESTING THAT
IS.
BEING. RECLASSIFIED BY THIS
BILL.
IT IS NOT A LOW LEVEL OF TESTING
ALL OF THESE TESTS ARE DONE
MANUALLY THEY ARE DONE BY A.
COMBINATION OF MICROSCOPY. AND
ALSO THEY ARE GAUGED BY THEIR
INTENSITY.
FOR IN THE BLOOD BANK FOR THEIR
OF ABILITY TO.
THE REACTIONS WHICH CAUSE WHICH
IS NEEDED BY A.
HIGHLY TRAINED PERSON I ACTUALLY
HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
ADDITION TO MY BACHELORS AND
OVER TWENTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
AS A CLINICAL LABORATORY
SCIENTISTS ALSO IN THESE AREAS
WE HAVE SPECIALISTS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO TECHNICAL.
WE ARE SPECIALISTS IN BLOOD
BANKING WE A SPECIALIST IN
HEMATOLOGY.
ALL OF THESE TESTS ARE HIGHLY
COMPLEX INTENDED WAY OR ANOTHER.
I'M SORRY.
UP AND SO I AND I WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT ACTUALLY WITH
BLOOD BANKING.
AT THERE IS ARM. OUT STRAIGHT
TO ALL OTHER MODERATELY COMPLEX
TESTS.
THAT ANY TEST.
THAT IS.
DESIGNATED FOR HBO COMPATIBILITY
RECIPIENT OR THE DONOR MIGHT
USE.
HIGHLY COMPLEX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I JUST DON'T KNOW WORDS
AT ALL ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
DOCTOR AND.
I WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND TO
HEAR FROM THE PATHOLOGISTS
THEMSELVES AS WELL. I'M HAVING
PRACTICED IN THE HE ARE I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US TO
GET TIMELY INFORMATION AND THIS
DOES SEEM LIKE A.
MODERATE ATTEMPTS TO INCREASE
OUR ABILITY TO HAVE TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS TO. ANALYZE AND
ONE OF THE REASONS I'M GOING TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL AS IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE RATIO OF.
CLINICAL.
SCIENTIST TO THE EMERALD HE'S
AND BECAUSE YOU DON'T CHANGE THE
SUPERVISION YOU NOW HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HOPEFULLY TRAIN THOSE
COMMITTEES TO DO SOME OF.
THE TEST THAT ARE PUT FORWARD
AND THE BLOOD SMEARS AND
MICHAEL.
MICROSCOPIC URINALYSIS ARE
IMPORTANT STUDIES BUT I DO THINK
THEY ARE TEST THAT WE CAN HELP.
OUR ANIMAL TEASE TO BE TRAINED
UP TO AND I'M HOPEFUL WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL HAVE
AN INCREASED OPPORTUNITY TO.
BE ABLE TO GET MORE TIMELY
INFORMATION AND TO BE ABLE TO
RETAIN OUR SPECIALIST SO. WITH
THAT I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS MATTER
FORWARD AND.
.
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
RICKETY MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN
COMMENTS AND AND THESE ARE THE
THREE TESTS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
A MODERATE COMPLEXITY AGAIN I
WILL SAY THAT BY THE TIME CLIA
AND AND IT DEFINITELY.
SHOULD BRING MUCH MORE.
EFFICIENCY TO THE LAB SO
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THIS DOES
ENJOY A AND. I RECOMMENDATION
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I'D LOW I
GROW. ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHILLED.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
AND WHEN I MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH.
TING.
THAT IS THAT A TWELVE VOTES.
MOST EXCELLENT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHOR.
IF YOU VERY MUCH MR WHEN.
WE NOW I STILL HAVE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE LEFT TO
IN B. PRESENTED NONE OF WHICH IS
FROM A SUMMER HOLDEN BUT HE IS
CURRENTLY. A NOT HERE IN THIS
ROOM SO WILL GO A TO A CALL FOR
THE CONSENT COUNTED TO BE
ADOPTED COMMITTEE SECTOR.
LOW. AYE LOW AYE BROKE.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLUE.
BLOOM AYE. JOB.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
BERMAN I MAYES. MAYES AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH TING.
THAT HAVE TO
TWELVE VOTES AMONG LEAVE THERE
WILL OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. OUT BLOOM NOW GO THEN
THROUGH THE.
OTHER BILLS IN.
FILE ORDER.
IN ORDER TO GET ADDITIONAL ADS
ON ADAMS.
INTO WE WAIT FOR.
MISTER HOLDEN TO PRESENT ON ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SO.
COMMITTEE SERVER WERE AT A FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE.
WITCHES AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLD.
ACTION IS DE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE STEINORTH. TING.
ONLY THAT
WILL OPEN AGAIN.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE MEMBERS
THIS WAS PRESENTED.
BY VICE CHAIR BRO OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATION AS I WITH THE
MEN'S AND THE.
AUTHOR HAS ALSO ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS
THE SECTOR.
ACTIONS DO PASTOR PREPARATION AS
AMENDED LOW AYE AYE LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BLOOM.
WHEN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. BERMAN AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN.
MORE I STEINORTH TING.
STEINORTH I.
THAT REALLY HAS TO ALL THOSE WHO
LEAVE THE ROLE FOR ADDITION OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL.
AT ARMS.
NOW GO ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
THIS IS AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
ONE BY SOME OF THE MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
ACTION HAS DAY PASSED LOW. ARE
LOW I BROKE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
LITTLE.
BLOOM I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
I WANT AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE TING.
THAT HAS TO ALL THOSE WHO
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
TRADITIONAL.
ANTON'S.
NUMBER OF ON THEN TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN LIVE NINE
BY JONES SAWYER.
ACTIONS DO PASSED COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT BRO.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
STEINORTH
STEINORTH I.
TING.
VETERAN HAS TEN VOTES AND LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS
AND ON I'M MEMBERS TO I DON'T.
.
IT'S C. NOW WE STILL HAVE
REMAINING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN.
ZERO FIVE BY SOME OF THE HOLES
IN ANOTHER SERGEANTS HAVE
ALREADY CALLED.
SOME OF HOLDEN TO PRESENT HIS.
FINAL BILL.
AND I SEE ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE SO UNLESS IT CAN
RESEARCH IT TO GO THROUGH OUR.
BILLS AGAIN.
AB TWENTY TO EIGHTY ONE I
ACTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
BROWN.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE.
TING.
THIRTEEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE ON FOR ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
PHONE NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE BY SUMMER
HOLDEN.
ACTIONS DO PASSED WITH MINUTES
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE TING.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE BY SUMMER VOEPEL.
ACTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SPROUT.
BAKER.
BAKER I.
HOLDEN.
TING.
PHONE NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE SUMMER MURATSUCHI.
ACTIONS YOU PROSPERO.
ACRE
BAKER I.
HOLDEN.
TING.
FILE NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY NINE BY. SOME EVER
JONES SAWYER.
ACTIONS DO PASSED COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT PRO.
HOLDEN.
MAYES.
MAYES I.
TING.
AND THEN.
FUN WE ALSO HAVE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
BROWN'S.
HOLDEN.
STEINORTH SON OF AYE TING.
OKAY WHAT WILL GO BACK TO A TO A
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE.
SO AGO.
.
WE JUST AT CALL DID YOU TO
VERIFY ANOTHER MEMBERS AND WE
CONFIRMED THAT HIS VOTE WAS I'M
THOSE ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON.
AND THAT WILL GO TO A CONSENT
CALENDAR AGAIN.
AND THE ITEMS UNDER CONSENT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER
EIGHT.
WOW.
HOLDEN.
TING.
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE JONES
SAWYER.
BRO.
BAKER.
BAKER NOW.
HOLDEN.
TING.
IT VERY MUCH.
SOME EVER HOLDEN MIGHT YOU BE
READY TO PRESENT.
GREAT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
THIS IS AB TWENTY SVEN ZERO
FIVE AND OUR FINAL.
BILL PRUDENT PRESENTED TODAY.
SEND THEM A HOLDEN PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER IT.
SEC.
OURS IS ASKING THE STUFF I SAID
IS THIS EASIER THAN THE LAST ONE
SHE SAID.
I THINK YOU FOR THAT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
OH FIVE WHICH BRINGS PARITY TO.
OUR WORKERS COMPENSATION LAWS
FOR CONTRACTORS.
CONTRACTORS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE.
THIS PROBLEM THIS PROTECTS THE
HOME AND PROPERTY OWNERS THAT
HIRE THEM FROM LIABILITY IN CASE
OF ACCIDENT.
IT LICENSE OR UNLICENSED
CONTRACTOR DOES THAT DOES NOT
HAVE THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE THEIR CLIENTS CAN FILE
A COMPLAINT. WITH THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
FOR RESOLUTION.
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD HAS
TWO YEARS FROM THE DATE OF THE
VIOLATION TO INVESTIGATE.
BUT IF THE CONTRACTORS ON
LICENSE.
AND THE STATURE LIMITATION IS
ONLY ONE YEAR.
DUE TO THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES TO REPORT A VIOLATION AND
INVESTIGATE TOO MANY OF THESE
VIOLATIONS BY UNLICENSED
CONTRACTORS. ARE GOING ON
PROSECUTOR.
THIS BILL.
WE'LL BRING PARITY TO THE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS BY GIVING
THE BOARD TO USED TO INVESTIGATE
WORKERS COMPENSATION VIOLATIONS.
WHETHER THE CONTRACTOR.
WAS LICENSE OR UNLICENSED.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TODAY MICO
JIM NETSKY.
FROM THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE AND BOARD AND MARIA
GARCIA OF THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THEIR AS
ARGUED IN A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND SO ON. MEMBERS ARE AMINO.
WITNESSES WHICH ANYTHING IN
SUPPORT OF UP TO TWO MINUTES
PLEASE PRESENT WHATEVER IT.
MY MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING.
MY JOHN THAT'S KEY WITH THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
OF LEGISLATIVE DIVISION. HAS AYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN MENTIONED
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE CONSISTENT
THE PERIODS IN WHICH TO
PROSECUTE LICENSE AND UNLICENSED
CONTRACTORS FOR WORKERS COMP
VIOLATIONS. THE BIGGEST ISSUE
HERE IS NOT OUR PROACTIVE
COMPLAINTS COM NOT THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND COMPLAINTS BUT THE
COMPLAINTS THAT THE CONSUMERS
FILE DIRECTLY WITH THE
CONTRACTORS BOARD. DAY I TEND TO
FILE COMPLAINTS WITHIN SIX TO
EIGHT MONTHS SOMETIMES A YEAR OR
MORE AFTER THEY ARE HARMED BY A
CONTRACTOR AND WHEN THAT OCCURS.
DE STATUE LIMITATIONS PERIOD HAS
PASSED IN THE CASE OF UNLICENSED
CONTRACTORS.
ORDINARILY WE HAVE HAD FOR
YEARS TO INVESTIGATE.
VIOLATIONS OF.
BAD CONTRACT WITHOUT A LICENSE
IN FOUR YEARS TO INVESTIGATE I
ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATIONS BY
LICENSEES.
AND.
WHILE ONLY ONE YEAR TO.
TO.
LEE FOR VIOLATIONS THAT FOR
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS WHO USE
EMPLOYEES ON A JOB SITE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN REGRET GARCIA
WITH CREAM RHETORICAL ME HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
OTHER EFFORTS TO COMBAT THAT
GROUND ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ANYONE SAYS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEEN NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME HE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A
SECOND SOME OF HER HOLDEN DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ACCUSATORY PLEASE CALL.
ACTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE AYE LOW
AYE BRO. BROUGH I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BLOOM. WHEN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN FIVE HOLDEN
AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE TING.
THAT HAS THIRD THIRTEEN VOTES
AND BELIEVES THAT ROLL ON OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD
ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
HOLTON.
OKAY DEATH CHO COMPLETES ALL THE
BILL'S.
THAT BEING PRESENTED HOWEVER WE
WILL GO THROUGH ALL OF THE BILLS
GET INCLUDING CONSENT CALENDAR
AND WILL LEAVE SEVERAL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES. PASO
COMMITTEE SECRETARY LETTUCE OF
BEGIN WITH A FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE.
ACCESS THE PAST APPROPRIATIONS
BROW. BRO I HOLDEN.
PUT AN AYE TING.
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
THE BILL INTO ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE.
BY SOMEONE HOLD.
ACTION IS DUE APPROPRIATIONS
WITH AMENDMENTS.
TING.
ELEVEN ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
FILE ITEM NO FOUR AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE.
ACTIONS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO. ROLE AYE.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE TING.
FIFTEEN YEAR THAT GOES OUT.
ITEM THEN NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
AB TWENTY SEVEN.
ZERO FIVE.
ACCESS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE TING.
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY ONE.
ACTION IS THE PAST PRO.
WELL I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE TING.
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FOLLOW MEMBERS SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY NINE BY MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
ACTIONS DEPOSIT COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT PRO.
FROM NOW.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
TING.
I'LL MISS MESA FROM I TEND NOT
VOTING.
THE VOTE IS TWELVE TO.
THE BILL IS OUT.
AND THEN.
FUNDS TO CONSENT CALENDAR.
YEAH WHICH IS AGAIN OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AND EIGHT.
WELL.
WELL I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
TING.
TING AYE.
WEAVER FOR A FINAL NUMBER SO
WE'LL JUST HAVE THE ADD ONS
FROM.
FIND A MEMBER
.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE YOUR
HOUSE APPROPRIATIONS TING ARE
TING AYE.
AB TWO FOUR TWO THREE DAY PASS
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TING AYE TING AYE.
AB TWO FOUR EIGHT THREE D.
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHIANG KAI TING AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN OH FIVE DAY
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS TING I
THINK I.
AB TWO SEVEN NINE ONE ACTIONS DO
PASSED TING I THINK I.
AB TWO SEVEN NINE NINE DO PASS
THAT TO THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT TING AYE TING
AYE.
OKAY THAT YOU CAN YOU